negli ultimi anni ci faccio caso
spessissimo quando sono un evento da
questo lato da quel lato a un certo
punto mi fermo e guardo cosa stanno
facendo gli altri intorno a me come ho
fatto adesso le cose sono due o stanno
guardando gli parla oppure hanno gli
occhi bassi sui loro smartphone sui loro
tablet perché stanno raccontando quello
che sta succedendo
probabilmente se io fossi al vostro
posto in realtà l'ho fatto fino a 2
secondi fa dietro le quinte starei
magari mandando un tweet postando una
foto su instagram
magari sarei live su facebook per far
vedere a chi non è qui dentro oggi con
noi che cosa sta succedendo per portarlo
qui dentro anche se fisicamente non è
presente e curioso perché a quel punto
di solito mi trovo intorno due tipi di
persone metà di loro non si accorge
neanche di quello che sto facendo perché
sta esattamente facendo la stessa cosa
oppure sta cercando una presa di
corrente perché gli si è scaricato lo
smartphone capita
l'altra metà ti guarda perplessa invece
di seguire l'evento perde tempo sui
social media
prende una risorsa scarsa come il tempo
e lo perde sui social media stanno
vedendo queste persone il mezzo non
hanno idea del messaggio non hanno idea
di che cosa sto facendo stanno
giudicando un comportamento e lo
giudicano come esclusivo sto tenendo
fuori tutto il resto del mondo il solito
sono le stesse persone che utilizzano
virtuale con una connotazione negativa
ti perdi nel tuo mondo virtuale invece
di fare attenzione alle relazioni reali
invece di prestare attenzione a un
evento reale ti perdi quello che sta
succedendo intorno a te in altre parole
secondo queste persone noi siamo a
sociali qualche mese fa quando esplose
il fenomeno pokémon go la gente lo
scarico usciva in strada si incontravano
si davano appuntamento apposta per
andare a cacciare pokémon
per chi non l'ha utilizzato di fatto era
un applicazione è tuttora un
applicazione che ti permette di
esplorare ciò che ha intorno ma tramite
una tecnologia che si chiama realtà
aumentata ti fa vedere dei pokémon che
deve catturare esattamente lo scopo del
gioco fantastico il trionfo della
socialità e viva la gente esce di casa
per incontrarsi andare a cacciare i
pokémon non va bene neanche quello
perché visto si incontrano e guardano
gli schermi non si parlano questa gente
non si parla queste persone sono sociali
ea questa storia della socialità
non ci credo e ve ne racconto una che
vecchia di 60 anni negli anni 50 non
tutti si potevano permettere un
televisore era un oggetto piuttosto
costoso
allora quello che classicamente
succedeva era che la sera in cui c'era
il programma di punta poi non è che
fossero esattamente molti programmi ci
si vedeva ci si incontrava a casa di chi
aveva un televisore quindi ti ritrovavi
intorno amici parenti vicini figli
mariti mogli tutti con gli occhi fissi
su quello schermo per guardare la tv il
televisore diventava un aggregatore
sociale
passano gli anni arriva il boom
economico aumenta la programmazione
aumentano i broadcaster aumenta
l'offerta televisiva arriva pure la
segmentazione dei programmi per cui ci
sono i programmi sportivi i programmi
apposta per i bambini programmi pensati
più per un pubblico femminile via
dicendo però aumentano anche televisori
in casa è così ce n'è uno in salone ce
n'è uno in cucina un in camera da letto
a volte anche uno nella stanza dei
bambini risultato mentre qualcuno guarda
una serie tv in camera da letto qualcun
altro sarà vedendo la partita in salone
qualcun altro sta vedendo i cartoni
animati
siamo tutti sotto lo stesso tetto ma
siamo sociali siamo disgregati passano
ancora gli anni i social media come li
conosciamo oggi restituiscono alla
televisione quel valore sociale che
aveva perso quella dimensione di
partecipazione e il fenomeno del secondo
screen
io guardo qualcosa in tv e intanto lo
commento su twitter in tempo reale con
altre persone utilizzando un hashtag una
parola chiave che si lega a quel
programma e che aggrega tutte le
conversazioni
quindi io e centinaia di migliaia di
altre persone come me
discutiamo di quel programma ci
aggreghiamo intorno a quella stage cdse
aggreghiamo alla fine del programma ed
eventualmente ci tra virgolette diamo
appuntamento alla settimana successiva
vi do qualche numero recente
quest'estate c'erano le olimpiadi su
twitter vengono inviati 187 milioni di
tweet che si legano un evento di rio su
facebook le interazioni sono 17,1
miliardi
intorno alle olimpiadi michael phelps il
campione di nuoto fa una serie di video
live su facebook che ricevono 4 milioni
di visualizzazioni
numeri che sarebbero quasi da prima
serata fino a qualche anno fa
numeri straordinari perché si può fare
perché abbiamo il potere di farlo
dieci anni fa time come ogni anno dedica
la sua copertina alla persona dell'anno
era il 2006 la persona dell'anno era you
to youtube aveva appena un anno era nato
nel 2005 ha già avuto un successo
straordinario aveva insegnato il mondo
una cosa fondamentale
se tu hai qualcosa che ritiene
importante dire e soprattutto
condividere quindi e rendere sociale nel
senso più puro del termine
puoi farlo perché io ti do uno strumento
a basso costo accessibile e semplice da
usare che ti permette di farlo dieci
anni dopo quel tu è diventato un noi
continuiamo a raccontarci continuiamo a
farlo continuiamo di fatto a rendere gli
altri partecipi di quello che ci succede
ieri facebook ha annunciato che negli
stati uniti e in gran bretagna stava
acquistando degli spazi pubblicitari
tradizionali quindi fiancate di autobus
cartellonistica stradale pubblicità sui
giornali e riviste semplicemente per
ricordare a tutti che se in questo
momento
state vedendo qualcosa che vi interessa
condividere con gli altri
premete un tasso andate live fatelo
vedere a tutti a luglio
qualche mese fa daimon reynolds una
ragazza americana aveva mandato live il
fermo di polizia del fidanzato era
insieme a lui col fermo di polizia
ha come esito l'assassinio del fidanzato
per la prima volta abbiamo visto un
assassinio in diretta abbiamo cominciato
a farci domande sulle responsabilità è
giusto che venga consentito che si
faccia una cosa del genere giusto
vederla è giusto che non venga censurata
da chi e perché e perché non dovrei
poterla raccontare la settimana scorsa
altro cambiamento epocale nella storia
dell'umanità channel four e al jazeera
dicono che avrebbero trasmesso live e
l'hanno fatto
le operazioni militari per la ripresa di
mosul
noi abbiamo avuto racconti di guerra
straordinari da erodoto passando per
cesa regole il suo de bello gallico
andando avanti poi nei secoli ci siamo
sentiti raccontare tantissime guerre
abbia visto foto che ci hanno portato in
quei posti abbiamo sentito testimonianza
abbiamo visto video ma noi non siamo mai
stati veramente sul posto
adesso sì adesso siamo sul campo di
un'operazione militare in tempo reale
siamo lì dentro ci siamo abituati
talmente tanto essere partecipi che la
cifra della nostra presenza in un posto
pensateci il self qualche settimana fa
girava questa foto di hilary clinton
aveva terminato un incontro con i suoi
sostenitori
era su un palco ferma come sono io
adesso e da franchi era pieno di una
platea di persone che le davano le
spalle non stavano andando via
stavano scattando un self che dimostrava
che loro in quel momento erano lì con
hillary clinton
erano presenti in quel posto lo volevano
condividere con gli altri
abbiamo un potere straordinario nel
palmo di una mano e ce l'abbiamo tutti
ed ha cambiato tutto perché tutti quanti
dal nostro punto di vista è univoco che
parcellizzato che in effetti è il nostro
appunto è soggettivo riusciamo a
restituire il racconto del real è
effettivamente noi siamo diventati la
notizia noi ci siamo abituati
le notizie non passano più solo dai
mezzi tradizionali ci siamo anche
abituati essere diffidenti sappiamo
benissimo che certe notizie adesso vanno
verificate però sappiamo anche
e quando nel 2009 l'iran diceva è tutto
sotto controllo
ci sono giusto alcune manifestazioni ma
tranquilli va tutto bene
twitter ci racconta un'altra storia non
stava andando tutto bene abbiamo visto
poi con la primavera araba
abbiamo visto la polizia di bruxelles
chiedere di smettere di twittare delle
loro operazioni militari dopo gli
attacchi terroristici per non far capire
terroristi cosa stava succedendo e
twitter si è riempita di gattini per
coprire letteralmente i tweet di chi
stava raccontando quelle operazioni ci
siamo abituati che le notizie nascono
dal basso che anche noi possiamo
effettivamente essere quella notizia in
quel determinato momento
noi non siamo a sociali
noi siamo al contrario diventati degli
azzerato ri di distanza
noi siamo il mezzo ma siamo anche il
messaggio e lo siamo nello stesso
momento lo siamo contemporaneamente
perché noi
fatemelo dire siamo schermi grazie
la casa
scusate ma secondo voi dopo dieci minuti
che parlo di schermi ma me ne potevo
andare senza che ci scappasse in un self
insieme no mi piace pazienza siete
pronti
scusate le spalle e necessario al mio
via di de tuti the dix pronti devo
girare la camera 321 rifacciamola che
viene meglio pronti
ecco adesso ci siete tutti 3 2 1
prossimamente sui nostri schermi grazie